so many people come to California
because they see it as as as you know
you need
you know it's heaven you know and of
course television hasn't helped because
ask anybody you know particularly east
of the Rockies and they all think that
all Californians drive convertibles go
to the beach have a big dog in the back
of the car and sit all day drinking beer
you know because that's what California
blondes
that's what California is all about well
that's what commercials have been about
for many many years but that's not what
California is about if you're if you
know anything about California and among
other things I'm native born Californian
and I'd you know studied this state
fifty years or more you realize that
this state is so topsy-turvy it's like a
roller coaster gone bad it it can be a
boom state economically one one year it
can be in the whole thirty billion
dollars the next it can be a state that
embraces immigrants as it has in the
past at times it can be a state that is
absolutely done everything it could to
make immigrants feeling one cool
uncomfortable it can be a state where
there's nothing but you know of flowing
water enabling everybody to grow and and
and use for whatever purposes and it can
be a state another five or six years
later where there's nothing to drink I
mean there are so many extremes in
California and just when we think we're
sort of going to get it to get on top of
things
it would walk down so so that's why I
said the rise and fall it comes and goes
up and down but at the end of the day
it's certainly I think the most exciting
place to be
well the rise of course has been up and
down it's not just at one one ascendance
you know California had an incredible
boom with with the Gold Rush that's what
start at all you know and all these
people came to California and of course
they basically stole the state I mean
obviously some historians would put it
more gently but but that's what happened
you know stole the state largely from
the Native Americans
and the Spanish turned Mexicans by that
time Mexico because of its revolt from
Spain had been running California and
that's why they call it the Bayer revolt
which wasn't much of a revolt about six
shots you know but the idea was that
relatively few white men all who would
come here and believe me it was hard to
get here
staged a coup and and it became an easy
thing to do
once the Mexico signed the Treaty of
Guadalupe Hidalgo in Texas ending ending
the mexican-american war and and so that
that sort of sent the set the stage you
know for the bear revolt as its called
and Boyd the state just boomed you know
during during the gold rush that you
know they couldn't come here fast enough
and it's also the point in time when we
saw the first great immigration wave a
Chinese coming to California to to help
the next segment of that boom and that
was the Transcontinental Railroad so for
those for those thirty years or so there
was an awful lot of hustle bustle in
this state it was changing left and
right and and and and and and become it
became more diverse and the people with
money came into this state and the
railroad owned this dated so all these
things happen in a very brief thirty
years or so and you could argue that
during that period Wow we were going up
we were going way up and then of course
things changed not that we had to go
immediately down but we had a period
where California was rather tranquil the
gold the gold rush ended abruptly almost
it seems and this became sort of an
agrarian state after a World War Two of
course the vab was very important here
all these people who worked uh you know
Rosie Riveter types and they were plenty
as well as the military guys coming home
they all got VA loans it was a golden
period the late 1940s it was great
people were adjusting you know the men
were going back to school you know and
all that kind of stuff and California
had a history once it developed it's
it's a higher education system of
Believe It or Not making college free it
was free during the 50s and 60s as the
state put together its its higher
education program you know
university colleges and community
colleges and it didn't last long enough
as far as far as I'm concerned booze in
the mid-60s when when Reagan became
together 1966 that's when he and the
Board of Regents began to install
tuition for UC and the CSU followed and
then community colleges you know not so
much but but you know there was a very
golden period and then you know during
the 50s there was a lot of other
manufacturing here a lot and all of all
the parts that go with automobiles okay
and other manufacturing California was a
big manufacturing state that does the
70s 80s were a bit more difficult a bit
more difficult you know the the pulse
wasn't beating quite so hard and quite
so fast and quite so loud and so the
state began to go into a very serious
period of discrimination and
particularly against immigrants and
variants people don't remember this
anymore but during the 80s and the 90s
we passed some of the harshest
anti-immigrant legislation you could
ever imagine
one proposition proposition 187 would
have denied as I've called the time
illegal immigrants any benefits provided
by the state including education most of
it was thrown out by the federal courts
another another proposition during that
period made English the state's official
language another proposition during that
period of voters passed all these things
margin ended affirmative action we ain't
we were in the first states to end the
permit of action so people don't
remember this but during the late 70s
80s and 90s this place really went
backward in terms of a number of the the
social issues of people talk about today
so and if this is part of California and
and with it's all turned around the
California in terms of immigration you
saw during the 70s 80s and 90s you
wouldn't recognize because today this is
one of the most Pro immigrant states in
the country why well all you have to
look at is the fact that non-hispanic
lights or a majority of the population
and and their numbers of now
moved up in the state legislature and in
local offices and so you know because of
that incredible growth of these various
minorities the state has become much
more sensitive and so now of course
driver's licenses for undocumented
immigrants now they can go to college
and get state loans and state aid these
undocumented immigrants can sanctuary
cities have popped up everywhere and as
we speak
the state is on the verge the
legislature on making California the
first fully sanctuary state so the
changes that go on here you know are
like massive waves you know only the
waves don't always go in the same
direction you know and they battle
better things one one way they batter
things the next that's part of the
excitement of the state it's part of the
exhilaration of the state and for some
it can be the heartbreak of the state
now when you look at the Central Valley
which is about 400 miles long the
richest land you'll find anywhere the
only missing ingredient is water and
there have been some water wars that
will well they make movies either in
Chinatown you know the way Los Angeles
stole water you know from the Owens
Valley water wars in the state larger
than just that little area largely
because 80% of the water is number one
owned sugar goes to agriculture okay 80%
or agricultural related activities that
leaves 20% for the rest of the state
including people who like to drink it a
couple of times a day
add to that seventy five percent of the
water in this state comes from Northern
California the Sierras and in the rain
in Northern California 25% of about 25
two-thirds excuse me that's two-thirds
one-third of the water one third of the
water is generated in Southern Company
but the problem is Southern California's
got two-thirds of the population and
Northern California which by the way are
very generous with because for a lot of
people that start just north of the
hatch appease you know don't don't tell
that to the people in real Northern
California because
as far as they're concerned we're all
urban scum but but the fact that most of
the water is in Northern California most
of the populations in Southern
California that sets up a problem in
itself add to that that agriculture uses
about 80 percent of the water you know
sets up an incredible competition and
fight really between farmers and
environmentalist coupled with urban
users so the you know the battles here
you know our our endless ways to you're
not going to find more water in
California just not you know if you're
lucky you'll get a decent year you're
not going to plan by the way you count
on the snowpack because it snowpack
alone counts for one-third of our water
no snow you're in trouble
you've got to draw from the Colorado
aquifer the aquifers in the Central
Valley which now have been drained
thanks to the drought so farmers are
always looking for water and the
environmentalists are always saying the
more water you take especially from the
Delta water coming down the rivers that
would otherwise go into Delta and you
circumvent that Delta and pour it into
agriculture the more you're endangering
fish and lots of other species that's
one of the the headaches that we've had
here for the last Oh 40 years it's kind
of funny right now because we talk about
President Trump saber-rattling and
talking about denying California money
if the sanctuary cities and states don't
cooperate
fact of the matter is California's a
donor state but that I mean the state
contributes billions of dollars more to
the federal government then we get back
to donor states one of the the largest
donor states around you know Mota state
to the south their recipient States
states in many states in the Midwest
same thing so so it's ironically the
poorest states are the ones that get the
most of the federal government the
richest states are the ones who don't
they could drink to the federal
government it's been an off-and-on
relationship I will say that having
somebody like Nancy Pelosi
as Speaker even as minority leader has
been helpful to this state our two
senators for the longest time Dianne
Feinstein and recently until recently
Barbara Boxer had great seniority in the
Senate that matters it does right or
wrong we have 53 members of the House
the largest delegation by far although
rarely do they actually vote together in
a unified way but they can and when they
do their votes can count for a lot you
all add up all those things and we met
and we've got the brains here and that's
not to say there aren't brains other
places but there's such a concentration
of talent here it's such a concentration
you know of so many smart people who are
doing so many things innovation is just
it's one of those things that happens
all the time
and no it doesn't always work but it
does what it does it just changes
everything there's a sign as a book if
you go to Facebook that company you know
there's wacky things all over the place
I remember one time walk into Facebook
and I saw this sign on a white wall fail
first ask for forgiveness later that
kind of mentality exists there it
doesn't exist so much in Washington
right Washington is this is the way
we've done it they were always going to
do it and blah blah blah so Washington a
status quo California is the Wild West
and so there's a culture differential to
begin with okay they're very different
places and and I think that sometimes
cause attention it depends on the
administration Bill Clinton and Barack
Obama saw great benefits in California
managed to get Congress oftentimes to
funnel us money for mass transit for Rd
help out with h-1b programs you know
other federal funds for space
exploration things like that because
well as talent here George W Bush was
rather benign he didn't really love it
or hate it I think we pretty much even
understand it I don't blame him
and it wasn't very outward on all that
stuff and Trump is going to be
interesting now some people are already
pull
your hair out because you know Trump
hates Californian air mines I'm not so
sure he hates California maybe does but
but but let's remember we've got Kevin
McCarthy who was the majority leader
here and we've got some pretty sharp
people Republicans and Democrats in
Congress which will be able to exercise
a lot of common sense and and leverage
so I'm not so sure that that even
someone like President Trump will be
able to turn the state upside down but
but you know it's definitely going to be
a different era it has to play itself
out California matters because it's so
often the first and it's not the first
it's really about the first but if you
look at things like environmentalism
gosh California and by the way Democrats
and Republicans Arnold Schwarzenegger
will go down in history for a lot of
things but in terms of his governance
the legacy will be something called a
t32 which was the bill that initiated
California developing a larger and
larger percentage of its of its power
from alternative energy way ahead of
everybody else
way ahead ok and coming up with what we
call cap-and-trade
which basically taxes companies that use
too much fuel this was pretty amazing so
environmentalism is being here
the women's movement is being here one
third of our Congress is women is female
you know that's about double the
national average minority rights have
have become big here one third of our of
our Congress our membership is minority
which also is double close to double the
national average so these are all
movements here so this state in so many
ways has set the trend not always in the
right direction for some people but is
it transferring and this isn't you can
view this as a country it is the sixth
largest separated from the nation it is
the sixth largest country in the world
in terms of economic development the
only five nations that are more powerful
than us in terms of the economy
so we've used that leverage in lots of
ways to move ahead and a lot of states
have come to emulators some of the
states it had come to Lotus
my hope would be that people learn more
about California it's it's a very
exciting place it's a very fast-paced
bikes not fast place like New York City
but fast paced in the sense of so many
things come and go so many developments
rise and fall so many innovations come
and change the world not only our
country I'd like them to realize that
they that they that the complexity of
the state the diversity of the state is
also the bounty of this state there's so
much we learn from each other in
California it's it's it's a state where
everybody can somehow get some
representation depending about whatever
group or groups they belong to it's a
state also a great conflict you know
they're are competing values in this
state there's a place for everybody in
the state the far right has its legions
in California believe you me and and and
the left of course does as well but but
it's a state with it where there's so
much action and so much activity so much
energy I think for that reason it's
exciting it can be tiring it can be
tired it can be exhausting especially
when you try to figure out Sacramento
and figure out what what the legislature
doing and not doing in a tax collection
system as whacko bananas and there's all
kinds of problems here but problems are
not it's a state that looks to move you
know most of the time forward sometimes
not but it's a state that looks to move
and never never rest on its laurels and
you know it's a pretty exciting place to
be